a North Carolina mother says a location
sharing app helped her rescue her 17
year old daughter after the teen crashed
her car and landed at the bottom of a
25-foot ravine CBS n anchor and CTM
correspondent vladimir duthiers is back
Vlad what happened here this is a
fascinating story
Katrina Alexander's daughter Macy missed
her curfew and wasn't answering her
texts so using the find my friends
application Alexander noticed Macy had
been in the same location for too long
and left together
she found Macy pinned under her car take
a look can you imagine a mom seeing that
so what had happened Maisie hydroplane
and crash and was stuck for seven hours
she broke her neck and a severe nerve
damage in one arm but it's already
regaining some feeling they're
encouraging families to use location
sharing technology like this in case of
an emergency
so apps like find my friends let people
track friends and family using GPS
technology you choose which contacts can
see your location and for parents or
kids who are worried about privacy you
can actually toggle a location sharing
off and on so it can only be active when
kids are driving or when they're walking
or they're home alone and there are a
lot of apps like this out there for
families to look for they can help put
parents minds at ease because your
children are out and you don't know what
could be happening to them in this case
this was a story that ended I know kids
don't always like it when you track but
in this case it was it was really
unfortunate I know for example my sister
I took my nephew out one day and then
she literally texted me and she goes
where you taking Gabe I was like okay
now you're tracking him so they if you
have him they're really good yeah good
as she's good to see she was smiling
there in those pictures yes yeah Vlad
thank you so much